we're going to try to talk about how to
harness a critical organizational
resource for your team's which is the
information and expertise of the people
who inhabit your organization and the
question is how do you get them into
your teams with that critical
organizational resource that information
that they have the expertise they have
and then how do you once it's there get
it to surface get it so that other
people could take advantage of that and
the way we're going to be able to do
that is tonight is to really sort of
participate in a little exercise which
most of you I'd say probably about 99%
of you somebody may have done it but
most of you haven't done it so you may
not know the punchline yet and then what
we'll do is I'll then talk about looking
at this from the context of how do we
think about in terms of what we learn
from the exercise how do we think about
that in terms of identifying the
resource having in our teams and and
surfacing that expertise in our teams
and then what we're going to do is make
an application through the through a
quick case study and we'll use that to
really think about how to become more
effective and efficient in our teams as
well as more valuable about making those
teams more valuable for the organization
this exercise is about an important
resource that's where Maggie started our
conversation tonight is that we're gonna
talk about an important resource the
important resources we're going to talk
about is the fact that people can look
at the same thing and see completely
different things in this exercise all of
you looked at exactly the same sentence
and yet I mean you saw the incredible
variety of opinions we had the first
time around about how many FS there were
in this sentence and let me point out
something to you
this is a relatively easy task
right I mean seriously right a lot of a
lot of the problems that we run into in
organizations the answer is not that
obvious and yet when we have different
people looking they're gonna see
different things that ability of
different people to look at the same
thing and see different things in a
critical organizational resource I want
you to think about the fact that this
ability to look at the same thing and
see different things is part of what
gives us the ability to be creative
it's part of what gives us the ability
to be innovative it's part of what
allows our organizations to adapt
effectively but in order to do all those
things to be creative to be innovative
to be adaptive to be a successful
organization we have to learn how to
harness this resource we have to learn
how to marshal this resource in our
organization so I'm now going to turn
the floor over to Margaret and she's
going to tell you how to marshal and
make use of this resource so the cool
thing I'm going to talk about here is
and sort of what I focus on is our
really our more heads better than one
and we want to really focus here on that
the the issues that we really raised
here and we raised in our process is you
know are there ways to identify how we
get these different eyes to actually
look at the problem that our teams our
organizations are facing and then if
they have some some ideas they want to
present some perspectives they want to
present how do we get those raised in
the team and then addressed in the team
and so the question here is looking at
differences and conflict as to critical
organizational resources in team
performance now one of the things I
think is important for us to consider is
you know we've all been in teams and
lots of teams and you know that the sort
of subtitle here is are more heads
better than one and the question is if
if teams bring more resources to the
table how is it possible that more heads
are not better than one all right we've
got people you know lots of smart people
on our organization looking at this
process
how can it be welcoming we worse off and
one of the things that happens is we
have something called process loss and
that is we're actually having more
people leads to less good outcomes and
the question is what happens in those
kinds of teams where we see this kind of
process loss occur what we typically
would want is process gain right we want
some synergy to be created and yet in
some teams what we see is they literally
suck the life out of what's going on
right they make us worse off rather than
better off and the
is why does that occur and there a
couple of reasons why that happens the
first is that it turns out that actually
managing teams is difficult we've got to
do things that we don't have to do if
we're making a decision by ourselves and
part of it is understanding what are the
decision rules how do we know when we
have a decision right is it you know do
we have a leader or do we have a manager
and that person listens to the advice of
the members of the team and makes the
decision and my behavior might be very
different as a team member if that's the
rule that's being used versus majority
rule let's just take a vote and see what
we do my behavior would be very
different in that sort of situation or
if it's by consensus right if all these
kinds of decision rules affect the
process of how we come to a decision in
addition we've got to be able to
establish common ground and coordinate
team members and that may take a lot of
time and effort especially for example
if team members are located across
geographical and time boundaries if team
members may be located across cultural
boundaries and that cultural boundary by
the way doesn't have to be country of
origin culture it could be a group of
engineers trying to talk to a group of
accountants okay there are huge cultural
boundaries there that we have to forge
it could be that there's a difference in
the amount of knowledge or skill ability
communication capability of members of
the team we've got to learn how to
interpret our team members and what they
mean when they say certain things we've
got to respond to an issue of team
identity how is it we know who's part of
the team and who's not and how do we
decide if this team that we're part of
is worth the effort that we have to
contribute in order to get our positions
heard and our points of view across what
are some solutions and basically one of
the things that teams really report as
their greatest concern is managing
conflict and it turns out that that's
actually that's what we spend most of my
time talking about in teams and when you
ask people what they're concerned about
but the research is not supportive of
that
the research actually suggests that
there's some things that we do where
what our biggest fear should be is not
managing conflict but managing agreement
and that is we are too good at managing
agreement that is we get agreement in
our teams before we should because we're
afraid of the conflict we suppress
conflict and force a false consensus as
it were okay and so then what we've got
to do in order to try to avoid this
being too good at managing agreement is
we first need to think about how do we
put together our teams that is are the
resources that we will potentially need
to solve the problem available within
the context of the team and if they are
that sort of a necessary condition then
are we able to surface those differences
are we able to make sure that the
resources that are in the team are going
to be utilized okay and those are two
very different problems and require two
very different responses so let's first
talk about how we form teams and what
typically happens when teams are left to
form on their own is we actually use a
very simple heuristic that is let's form
teams of people like me right why do we
do that why is it that people want to
form teams of people who are like them
and I'll even let you guys answer this
because it's pretty obvious answer it's
more fun that way
right and if our biggest fear is
conflict right you know I've I have if
my friends are all here cuz what's the
best predictor of interpersonal
attraction who your friends most likely
to be like you right the people we like
are people who are like us in terms of
our goals and values experiences and so
hey let's bring them all together and
we'll find a way then to get around all
this conflict stuff and we will reach
agreement very quickly
all right well of course what does this
do it minimizes the information
perspective the diversity information
diversity of the team now there's some
wonderful advantages and the biggest
advantage of course is less console
but there are officers of others the
secondary advantage is one is that
homogeneous teams and his team is
composed of people just like me actually
are much more efficient in terms of
getting the work done okay they get to a
solution quicker there could be some
cost to that too but their effect you
know if what we're measuring is how fast
do we get out of this team meeting this
is the way to go okay that's your
primary measure of quality we get
validation of position you know I like
people like me because they think like
me and when they think like me well you
know and we have a problem to solve we
all come up with the same answer okay
we're done we can get out now right you
sort of see how this thing works
is that if we all come from the same
perspective then we're all gonna
actually probably focus on the final
solution will be but we all believe it
to be there's not gonna be very much
divergence of opinion and so there's no
conflict once again that no conflict
goal and by the way it makes that mix
because that friendship is one of the
big norms right it reduces the
likelihood we'll be thrown out of the
group right and one of the big concerns
we have in teams in our organizations in
our social life is who's in and who's
out and please don't let it be me right
I want to be in this group I want to
have be part of this group I don't want
the group you know exclude me and so
these kinds of teams actually reduce the
probability that people will be excluded
because we're so similar
well the disadvantages also exist and
the first disadvantage is that if we you
know the title was our more heads better
than one well if you have the same head
repeated four times it's not clear it's
better if what you're trying to do is
solve a problem because the information
that's available is pretty much your
information repeated four times at
pardon its louder yes it's loud and you
know what it's sort of like if it's loud
because if the echoes are all the same
right so it reverberates against itself
in addition what happens is there is
very little capacity to learn in a team
like that and the reason they're such
says that this is a big important
problem it's because we don't like to
learn we don't like it's a hard thing to
do and so if we don't see the pressure
that is we don't see the discrepancies
that exist between what we hope for and
what is then what we're gonna do is
think everything's fine and go on
I mean rarely do if we all agree on an
answer do we then say you know let's
come back around and say well one of
those answers we didn't think about
right we say we're done we don't want to
be in this meeting much longer we've got
lots of other stuff to do we all agree
on it
let's go right and so what happens is
the teams lose the capacity to learn
because they're not faced with
discrepant information with divergent
information in addition it also because
it lacks the capacity that is we don't
have anybody having a divergent view we
also don't have that motivation either
which is you know okay it's gonna be
hard to do it's painful let's go ahead
and do it because we we need to be able
to do that and you get this wonderful
groupthink kind of notion we all look
around we all agree and so we are
actually more confident about the
correctness of our decision even though
what we've done is just repeat ourselves
four times right and so what happens is
we become much more confident much more
resistant to discrepant information that
may come from outside sources in this
kind of scenario well it used to be not
too long ago we there was a whole series
of research about how is it that
diversity and multiple types of
diversity one of which in the important
type we want to focus on here is
informational diversity how is it a
diversity affects outcomes you know for
example creativity Greg talked about
adaptation those types of performance
things that we care about in our
organization and the research early on
basically posited a direct relationship
that is if you create if you basically
have the potential in your teams for
informational diversity what you will
find is that the performances innovation
that sort of thing creativity will occur
this turns out not to be the case more
recent researchers argued that in fact
it's not under
recked relationship but it's a
relationship that has an important
component between diversity and outcomes
because there turns out to be no direct
relationship between having diversity on
a team and getting good performance what
you have to have in the middle its
conflict now you knew that right okay
what happens is that having diversity
having these differences of opinion and
expertise and perspective creates
conflict and it's the way in which the
group is able to handle the conflict
that allows the team to perform and so
we see two conditions that are now
necessary for performance in a team
first that there be the differences
there and secondly that those
differences be surfaced and addressed in
the context of the team so what are the
solutions how do we get to that place
where we've got both the diversity
existing and the conflict well first
what we want to do is we want to courage
conflict that arises from that diversity
in our teams right because of the
membership the differences in the
membership but we want to focus on and
the Cuyuna so we're encouraging conflict
which is sort of a scary kind of thing
to think about in the team if what we're
most concerned about is conflict now I'm
saying to you absolutely could encourage
that conflict but I want you to
encourage a specific type of conflict
and that's the cotton courage a specific
type of concept from a specific type of
diversity and that is I want you to
encourage the informational disputes
that is how do you think this would be
different right what are the whatever
you what is your expertise your
perspective say about the solution to
this particular problem it's just this
informational differences are based on
experience expertise the perspective
that people have the relationship to
what we normally think about as
diversity which is a scripting or
surface characteristics that is gender
race ethnicity culture right maybe a
signal of some underlying information or
expertise perspect
but it's an imperfect signal and so if
we focus on the surface characteristics
you know it's sort of there's a sort of
an observation I made about our past
president Bill Clinton
there are many observations that were
made by about him this one I can
actually tell a mixed company
because what mil Clinton did was he was
very committed to diversity it's one of
the strong stands that he took early on
in his first administration and so his
group of advisers was composed of male
and female black Hispanic Asian lawyers
now you know if you look across the room
you know there was a lot of quote you
know what we call a script of diversity
right but every one of his advisors had
been socialized about how to think
strongly socialized in a particular way
and so he might have had some little
differences you know southern lawyer
versus northern lawyer but you know in
the end he got lawyers he got a one
perspective right and so part of what
you need to sort of be aware of is yeah
diversity surfaced characteristics maybe
some signal about differences but what
we really are trying to get at is where
are the informational differences in our
organization that we can take we can
take hold of part of what you need to be
able to do as a manager of a team and
one of the first meetings you have and
the more the more diverse in perspective
your team members are the more you need
to do this is to have that meeting that
says why are we here and while I'm while
the team can handle the conflict of
having people have different views of
how to get to the common goal the team's
most teams can't handle can't survive
with different goals from team members
so my first meeting of the team is going
to focus on what's our goal what's our
mission let's talk about sort of where
it is and how we are aligned on that
that's that's where you want homogeneity
right you want everybody to think you
want everybody to have the same goal
once that exists people believe that
everybody has the same goal that cements
the team boundary which says why are we
here why are we in here versus
outside with the rest of the
organization and secondly what happens
and if I understand that you have the
same goals that I do I get I give it I
have a sense of benevolence of trust
that you may have different perspectives
because of your expertise but you're not
out to destroy us the team you know you
have good intentions and we need to so
it makes it easier for me to hear the
differences if I believe that your
intentions are malevolent I'm not gonna
listen to you right I'm gonna try to
marginalize you get you out but so
absolutely when you think about
diversity not.you know there's some
diversity that's that's wonderful in
teams and the diversity that is really
damaging is the different diversity and
goals and values well why is it people
may in fact have differences and not
talk about them and part of it I've just
sort of alluded to which is this notion
of being a part of the team if I have if
I understand what the basis for
membership is and I'm part of that group
I'm more likely to share my expertise or
my differences because I don't fear
exclusion I know that I'm an important
valued member of the group because the
biggest way the teams have control of
people and basically can can force
agreement right is if you either agree
with me or we exclude you right
exclusion is a very painful thing and we
try and we will adapt and you know
sometimes knowingly and sometimes
basically subconsciously adapt our
behaviors to be accepted in the team one
of the things that we talk about in
terms of cross-functional teams is early
on if you just watch a cross-functional
team and it's in it's in it's early
meetings you you will probably be
astounded if you're looking for this as
how much the teams talk about what they
have in common rather than what we want
them to talk about which is how they're
different
how what different perspectives they
bring they talk about all their
commonalities it's called a contrarian
and basically let me tell you what the
next description is marginalized member
right and part of what your job is as a
manager right is to make sure that
people don't do that
behavior and part of what you have to do
is sometimes you to pull them aside and
say you know what do you want to be
right as I do this last time with my
doctoral students do you want to be
right or do you want to be effective
which one would you like you know in
research meetings this is the correct
way to go maybe but what you got is a
group of people who are going to have to
work together do you want to be writer
effective if you are always the naysayer
in an or in a meeting you will be
marginalized I can guarantee it
part of what you've got to be able to do
is rotate that role so that some people
get to be the contrarian and you know
sometimes you have to sit on people
because they really want to be the
contrarian and you really have to say no
today what you're going to be is you're
going to be the facilitator no today
you're going to be the record-keeper
okay you're not going to be the
contrarian this is another thing that's
really hard to do is pick your fights
because I think it's important that
people share their differences right
that's what we're trying to talk about
here but part of it also is you've got
to be divergent get those differences
out and then convergent to come to an
agreement right and part of that's
negotiation skills too right of course
it always comes back to negotiation
they're definite secondly whether the
other things that we care about we may
actually not know what the rules are we
may be new to the group or we may we may
just be uncertain how is it they handle
disputes here do they handle disputes
right and so you kind of tone down your
concerns until you figure out the the
norms and then what may happen is you
figure out the norms the norms are we
don't do that here
right we don't have conflict in our
groups well you know they have conflict
somewhere and maybe in the hallways but
what happens then is not everybody gets
to participate and think about it right
and so it becomes very problematic not
everything has to be done in the body of
the team but if you're a facilitator if
you're the manager of that team you
really need to think about a couple
points that you need to pay attention to
and thank you for the segue because it's
right here and that is choose your team
members not everybody in your
organization has to be in the team right
think about identifying what are the
skills and abilities I need
right and pick people who meet that
think hard about whether while I'm
putting them on the team because well
they're made politically it's important
right or you know some other other
reason that is different from getting
the team to perform right sort of the
cover your back kind of perspective
right in addition and this is what I was
speaking to earlier you need to do that
search for common ground early on you
need to get everybody to publicly commit
to the goals and values of the team
that's very important it comes much
harder for them by the way to act at
odds with that what they've made a
public commitment you need to sign roles
and responsibilities and switch those
roles and responsibilities okay today
you get to be the contrarian but next
week I'm going to get to be the
contrarian this may seem simple-minded
but it turns out to be pretty effective
that is how do you define the problem
how do you find the task of a team and
defining it as a problem to be solved
brings the team together to exert its
effort in the common direction defining
the task as a decision to be made
Haydn's people's just attempts to win
right to win the outcome you know the
decision says well you know it's gonna
be mine or yours or their opinions who's
gonna win but a problem says there's an
answer here let's find it by the way if
you have a very person who does not
contribute giving them the
responsibility and the role may
facilitate their willingness to speak in
many respects for example identifying
somebody's expertise publicly and the
group will also do that right because
then they feel honorbound to share that
expertise you've just identified and
they gain status from that right so part
of his understanding what will get
people who are normally reticent right
and maybe structurally what is your role
it may be status trying to raise your
elevate the status someone who is
quieter because they feel like they're
either a don't know the culture or
they're low status so you can sort of
help identify and try to push up the
demands for them to be response to be
proactive encourage active debate okay
when people start having disagreements
about information you reward that
behavior
it's really good that's what we want
right I know it's tough when we have all
these divergent opinions but let's get
them out before we can come up to the
solution right reward people's attempts
to share their differences and finally
hold a second chance meeting it this is
a critical organizational decision
create a critical team decision then
what we want to do here is to be able to
make sure that the decision we made plus
we've made it we don't get too wedded to
having made it we can now think what was
this the best one let's at least go back
and look part of it is when you do that
common goal perspective you say you know
here's what we want to say we're going
to get there then what we say is what we
want here is because we all agree to
that common goal then we have to get the
best possible answer we're looking for
the best answer here what that requires
is that we actually are willing to state
our opinions and provide justifications
for those opinions and for the rest of
us to listen to those opinions right and
to try to go from because we're going to
try to do early the team if surface all
the differences and then the second part
of the team is really to bring the
differences together to a unique whole
which will help solve the problem right
so it's caught it's divergence and then
convergence and in fact part of what
you're going to find is is that people
have different skills right some people
can it can generate a lot of divergent
opinions and then you're going to need a
more of a facilitator to try to say okay
how can we solve these differences so
what I've got to do is I've got to
reward those things that that are that
really engage the intellectual conflict
and punish or clearly make as
unacceptable the emotional or
interpersonal conflict I've got to be
able to distinguish those right and so
part of its understanding what kind of
con and by the way your team members and
maybe you probably you too because
you're you know often just a member of
another team are not going to feel it's
not going to be fun pass conflict even
though it's absolutely critical for an
organization is not fun and so what
you've got to do is sort of you've got
to engage the emotional maturity of your
team as well so you know what we have to
do things that aren't fun but it's
important for the
performance and now with that I'm gonna
go to you because you got something to
do here right and I don't wanna take up
all your time
okay thank you so Maggie has laid out
for us a little bit about making sure
that this resource is available in our
groups and teams and also how to harness
this resource center groups and teams
what we want to do now is give you a
chance to try and apply this in a
real-world business setting and so what
we have for you is a very short case
this is about page and a half I'll just
take you a couple minutes to read what I
want to do is I want to divide you into
groups and what I'll offer you I know
over here we're gonna let you divide
yourselves into groups tonight I think
it'd probably be a little hard for us to
do that what I want you to do is a
couple things first of all take a few
minutes to read through the case and get
a sense of what the case is about as I
said it's very short case second thing
I'd like to do then is grab some people
around you and form a group try to make
your groups around five or six people I
think five or six people would be a good
size group and what we're gonna do is
we're going to give you some time to
address the two questions that should be
on the bottom of the case first question
we want you to address is what mistake
was made and who made it in the case and
the second question we would like you to
address is what would you recommend
about this mistake and who made it so
you know as a group address those two
issues we're gonna find out now what you
talked about in your groups before we do
that I do want to mention one thing
about what just happened in your groups
Margaret and I are both big believers in
practicing what we preach one of the
issues that always comes up when you
have particularly large groups is the
problem that there may be people who
feel reluctant to surface their unique
information or who may feel that there
isn't enough time enough air time to be
shared one of the ways we get around
this in big groups is by doing something
we call buzz groups and essentially what
you just did is what we call a buzz
group a buzz group is when you take a
large group and you break it up into
smaller groups and one of the things you
do when you break groups into smaller
groups there's actually a couple things
you do first of all you increase the
amount of
air time right so if we had all hundred
of you trying to talk about this case we
would never have had a chance for all of
the opinions all of the unique
information that's represented in this
entire group to get surfaced we've now
got a much better chance at getting all
those unique perspective surface because
we let you filter that information in
the smaller groups I might add that
another issue that of course we weren't
into is something to Maggie referred to
I think as spectators we're always
worried in groups that people have key
information that we don't get to hear
about because they spectate they don't
actually participate in the discussion
being a spectator is a direct function
of group size the larger the group is
the easier it is to spectate and when we
break groups larger groups into smaller
groups we really decrease the
probability that people can spectate and
in fact sometimes in my MBA classes we
get them all the way down to buzz groups
of size two and let me tell you in a
group of size two it's real tough to
spectate you know it's it becomes
obvious very quickly if you're not
participating in the discussion right so
we use buzz groups as a way of trying to
get people more involved the other thing
that it does though is it also allows us
to solicit unique information in a way
which is much less threatening to the
people who have it because now as we go
around the room and I ask you you know
what did your group discuss notice that
if you had kind of a wild idea you had a
chance to bring it up in your group you
had a chance to get a little validation
from your group and when you surface it
now you can represent it as your group's
idea right so now it's not my idea I'm
not gonna take a chance or a risk of
sounding like a lunatic in front of all
these people but I'm gonna say you know
my group sort of discussed this idea
what's my idea but my group discussed
this idea and here's what we might think
of as a good way of dealing with this so
we use buzz groups as a way of trying to
feat some of the very problems that we
were talking about earlier today we we
try and make it easier for people to
talk by virtue of increasing the amount
of airtime we make it easier for people
to talk by virtue of distancing them a
little bit from their responsibility for
wild ideas that they make him come up
with okay so I want to spend the rest of
our time talking a little bit about this
case and see if we can work back to
applying some of the ideas that Maggie
talked about to understanding what
happened in this case what went right
what
wrong and what we might recommend that
they do instead so let's start with the
first question and let's find out what
you talked about in your groups first
question is what mistake was made and
who made it let's let's get a volunteer
from one of the groups one of the groups
who do you think made the mistake what
mistake was it I want to make sure we
understand all the things that your
group came up with that Manson did wrong
okay so I want to go back to this you
said no agreement on the goal was Manson
part of this problem let's get some
other groups involved do you think there
was any sense you said he didn't get
agreement on the goal was there a sense
at the beginning of this case what the
goal was okay what do you think the goal
is in this case is there a goal the
board of directors Manson they seem to
agree and who knows maybe Manson has
convinced them because they don't know
and but he's convinced them and there
seems to be agreement at least at that
level I think this is part of the issue
that Patricia has raised at that level
of the organization there seems to be
agreement that there is a problem that
needs to be fixed and this problem has
something to do with the fact that they
anticipate scarcity and because they
anticipate this scarcity they want to
make sure they have access and they
somehow think that coordinating is going
to make sure that they eventually do
have this access they want to make sure
that they don't reach a point where they
don't have the raw materials they need
so they're gonna put in place some
process so they seem to have a sense of
what they want to achieve and it looks
something like this but I think that the
point the Patricia's group raised was
that and maybe this is your point as
well it's not clear anybody else the
organization knows about this problem
okay so this is one of the issues right
up front and that is that's you know
Manson did not get any agreement and
perhaps didn't share top management's
perspective okay so this is I think one
of the original issues that Patricia
raised is that there is this problem
there is a perception of the problem at
one level of the organization it's not
clear that anybody else in the
organization particularly the purchasing
agents down at the plant level have
figured out what this issue is or what
this problem might be
so Manson and the Board of Directors are
taking action to fix the problem that
nobody else actually realize exists so
the plant purchasing exacts may be
competing let me ask you something it's
Tony right is this competition good or
bad for the organization is this a good
reason to be coordinating if they're
competing for these resources should we
be coordinating or should we let them go
ahead and compete okay so this suggests
that's there may be some goal or mission
disagreement across levels of the
organization okay
I want to go back to Patricia's group
because they raised some other issues
we've got some other issues up here
about mistakes that Manson may have made
so I think the next thing you said was
they picked the wrong person right so
they've got this goal they've decided
they're gonna coordinate purchasing and
so they insert mr. post into this
position okay now why was mr. post the
wrong person okay so this suggests
something else that Patricia's group
certainly alluded to and that is that we
have to put post up here I think you
said there was plenty of blame to go
around so let's see if we can figure out
what we think that post did wrong and
let me emphasize something you know this
case is is very interesting on a lot of
levels a lot of people think maybe
Manson did something wrong a lot of
people think maybe post did something
wrong in real life most of us never get
to be Manson a lot of us get to be post
so I think it's it's real important for
us to figure out not only what post did
but what we can do to help post in this
process okay so Manson puts post in
place and what is supposed to do
okay its bureaucratic and large in this
little exactly what did posts do so no
information search instead I mean and
this really harkens back directly to
what Maggie talked about right we've got
all this unique information out there
and yet somehow post decides to make
this decision based on almost zero
access to this information I got to ask
you this question this comes up every
time I read this case what the hell is
he doing that he doesn't have time to go
out and meet these people I can't quite
figure this out I mean I'm too busy to
go talk to these people I just you know
I don't get it anyway I want to talk
about the letter for a minute yeah a lot
of a lot of people want to talk about
the letter as a vehicle for persuasion
or as a vehicle for management and what
do you think about this letter
okay I'm sort of hearing lots of
solutions so let me tell you the three
things that often come up and I think I
just heard all one is maybe nothing has
happened right so the plant purchasing
execs are sitting there going maybe if
we ignore this this will go away you
know okay so that's one possibility
another possibility is that they have
simply decided that they're gonna
circumvent this new rule and so my
$60,000 contract just became 230
thousand dollar contracts or that's
right or my 90 thousand dollar contract
just became two forty five thousand
dollar contracts and lo and behold
there's no reason for me to report to
mr. post in this process and of course
the other possibility is that post and
some of you've already alluded to this
possibility is that post picked the
wrong number because post really doesn't
fully understand what's going on in this
organization and in fact the average
contract turns out to be less than 50
thousand dollars so this is simply the
wrong number now the key that I think
you've raised here Celia is that he
doesn't even know post doesn't even know
which of these various possibilities has
occurred at the end of the case because
post really has not opened up this
channel of communication a lot of people
talk about the timing of this letter
a lot of people also talk about the tone
of this letter how would you
characterize the tone several of you
mentioned some words that you thought
sort of characterized what you think
about this bureaucratic autocratic yeah
okay so this is clearly very much one
way communication isn't it I mean one of
things that it clearly does not do is it
does not elicit information does not
elicit the unique information or
perspectives a unique information that
is available among these twenty plant
purchasing executives somebody to
rewrite this letter for me is there a
way even if we leave aside the fact that
the letter may not be the best strategy
for initiating this can you really like
this rewrite this letter in a way that
makes it a little bit more effective
what do you think let me just ask you a
real quick question do you think the
plant purchasing executives C post as a
solution or a problem a problem okay I
mean everybody agrees that they look at
this letter and they go oh she's one
more thing to do in the middle of this
busy purchasing period this is very good
I think the only hope that post has and
I think you're right Tony you can't
write the perfect letter because some
mistakes have already been made but the
only hope post has is to try and change
their perception to see post as a
facilitator of the solution to a problem
rather than as a new problem for these
people yes well this is certainly a very
interesting issue because once again
this depends on what it is that post is
doing in this organization so for
example if we and I'm sorry I don't know
your name
April so if if April's letter is
successful I'm not taking power away
from you I'm helping you do your job
more effectively you're gonna run into
problems and you know I think one of the
most interesting solutions I've ever
heard volunteered for this case is a lot
of people say you know if you went if
Manson went to the purchasing executives
and said the board thinks there's a
problem they think there's going to be
scarcity of resources what do you think
we should do about this that there is a
very large probability that the solution
they would have come up with is to hire
a post to hire
somebody to help coordinate this so that
we can see a little bit more about
what's going on now the difference of
course is that now it's their solution
and I think this is an important
difference is that it's entirely
possible that Manson and the board are
right it's entirely possible that
coordinating could be a very effective
solution to whatever problem they see
but I think what a lot of you have
touched on is that even if their
solution is correct the people down
below in the organization a don't even
know there's a problem and they're
certainly not sold on the fact that post
is a solution to whatever that problem
is to them post just looks like a huge
problem now I want to back up because a
couple of you have raised issues about
what post might have done instead and
one of the things that people always say
is that what post needs to do is
initiate communication if we go back to
what Maggie was talking about earlier
clearly this is an important solution we
initiate communication we at least open
up the possibility that if there is
unique information either about what
this problem really looks like or how
our organization can most effectively
solve it opening up that channel of
communication is going to give us the
best possible chance to solve that
problem where you get the most
perspectives the most expertise involved
in trying to initiate a solution how do
you think posts should do this okay so
one of the things that post can do is he
can go out and let's say you are our
plant purchasing execs you can go out
and visit all of these people and talk
to them and get their ideas are there
other solution certainly one of things
that's clearly missing from this letter
is whatever the information is that the
board or Manson had that somehow
justifies taking any action at all I
mean let's go back to the point that you
raised which is that the culture here is
that these people operate independently
we are now pulling the entire rug
apparently out from under this by
installing post in the middle to control
and command this process and although we
could rewrite the letter in a way which
at some level makes it a little less of
a command and control and more of a
facilitation role the fact is we're
still changing things so if there is
urgency you know one of the things that
we can do is we can try and communicate
some of that urgency so that the plant
purchasing executives own the problem
and once again
opening up the channel of communication
and I think this is a key issue in this
case it not only gives us information it
also gives us a chance to provide them
information and you know going back to
this idea of you know if Manson had gone
down and talked to these people you know
a couple things might have happened one
is they might have come up with post as
the solution or they might have come up
with another solution that is better
than post and which by the way does not
conflict with the current culture of the
organization and which really sits a
little better with them Larsson
definitely has some information that
post could use and I want to go back to
this point because one of the
interesting issues in this particular
case is let's say your post and you
don't think you can afford to not do
anything despite the time crunch you
don't have time to do all these site
visits and yet somehow you have to
jumpstart this process we've got most of
the solutions up here that people
usually come up with what you want is to
bring them in what do you think about
this bring them in solution do you like
this solution or not all right well let
me let me give you a suggestion to think
about in this circumstance which i think
is an interesting way to try and finesse
this problem a little bit and it brings
me back Tony to the letter and what
might have made this letter a little bit
more effective post clearly does not
have time to visit everybody and yet he
has to create a sense I think this
building trust is a very important point
I'm gonna add another word here which is
the word credibility I can imagine that
this letter would have been much more
effective if they believed post really
understood what was going on at their
level they don't really know anything
about him and I think going back to
Laura's point he's never seen their
perspective from their point of view
they don't know that he knows anything
about them one of the ways that he could
use Larsson very effectively was to ask
the following question and this it comes
to an idea you know we've been we've
been talking about the idea of
inclusiveness the idea of inclusiveness
is simply opening up those communication
channels and I think we all agree that
the letter was not a very effective way
of opening up because really it's just a
you know here's here's your order it's
not more along the lines of April's
letter G you know I
I'm new at this and any information you
give me would be helpful maybe if you
sent me you know any contracts over
fifty thousand dollars obviously he
didn't do any of those things he may not
have time to do the obvious solution
which is to go out and visit all the
plants so there may be an in-between
solution which is to visit some of the
plants and here's where Larson could be
an extremely useful person because one
of these that he could ask Larson is he
could say you know who are the opinion
leaders among these in who are the
ringleaders among the plant execs if
there are only a couple people like
let's say I'm gonna go visit Alan and
I'm gonna go visit Michael because I
know that if I get them on my side
everybody else will listen and now let's
imagine we can rewrite this letter again
Tony so now I write this letter in the
letter now says something like the board
thinks there's this problem who knows if
it's true or not what I want to do is I
want to see if we can try something this
time around I went and I talked to Alan
I went and I talked to Michael I got
some ideas from them and what we think
we're gonna do is we're gonna put in
place this mechanism where if you have a
contract that's over $50,000 you let the
head office know and that way we'll get
a sense we'll try to get our hands
around this particular problem I have to
tell you a story that I think relates
this very well I one of my students back
at the University of Illinois in the
Executive MBA program was hired as a
middle manager in the electric company
in the utility company and when they
made this appointment he came to the
company and he said before I become part
of the management staff headquarters
there's something I'd like to do I would
like to go out and work with one of the
crews that digs ditches and lays cable
and he literally went out for two weeks
and he dug ditches and he laid cable now
notice if he sends this letter that post
sent this letter probably gets a very
different reception because it's not
coming from this detached in
personalized headquarters this is
somebody we trust because he was down
here in digging ditches and laying cable
with us post I think could buy himself a
whole lot of credibility even if he just
visited one or two of these people and
you know I think for two reasons one is
first of all Alan and Michael are
totally gonna be calling all of you say
post came down and visited me this guy's
not such a bad guy after all he's not a
complete lunatic
you know let's cut him a little slack
and see where this goes but even if they
don't help me in terms of my credibility
the fact that I can even refer to the
fact that I went down I saw a little bit
about what this problem looks like from
their point of view it's clearly going
to be helpful in getting people to
accept my position in this and I think
as a consequence of that that letter
might be more effective for that reason
as well and once again very much like me
going out and just visiting a couple I
think you've refined this a little bit
by saying let's pick two that we think
may be really susceptible maybe the
board's information can help us identify
those who are the most vulnerable to
this problem
all of these are about the notion of
representative inclusiveness so
inclusiveness does not have to mean that
I talk to every one of you in this room
it does mean that I have to talk to
enough of you that the rest of you know
that I have seen enough of your
perspective that my decision-making can
take into account the kinds of unique
information that you might be able to
bring to the table by the way some other
interesting solutions that have been
raised for this case you know one
thing's we might also do is I could go
talk to Michael and I can talk to Alan
and I could say why don't you guys go
out and talk to some of these other
purchasing execs you know I'm sort of
new with this maybe you can give me a
little sense of whether you think this
is a real problem and if it is a problem
if the board is right what is it that we
can do to try and address this problem
and I think once again you know this
this gives us two very different things
first of all going back to Maggie's
point it gives us the unique information
it allows us a vehicle for drawing upon
the information that's available and
once again representativeness is a way
to get access to that information
without necessarily begging the chaos of
getting everybody involved in the
decision-making process but the other
really critical thing that it does is
that when we open up this channel of
communication if we open it up is a
two-way channel of communication we not
only get to find out what people's ideas
are what their unique information is to
help us inform better decisions we also
make them more owners of this problem
and owners of the solution and once
again I I go back to what I think is the
most key point in this case
if Manson had understood what all of you
now understand he would have talked to
the purchasing execs they may have
decided that they wanted to post and
their reception of posts would have been
completely different if it was their
idea than if it was Manson's idea you
know I think there's lots of ways we can
refine this representativeness this is
something by the way that you and a lot
of my classes you know in my classes I
want my classes to be a good learning
experience for my students because I
want my students to tell the university
that my class was a good learning
experience for them at the end of the
term and one of the ways did I manage
this is that I create an inclusive
vehicle in my classes what I do is I ask
my class is to elect a course committee
usually the second class of my course
and they elect two or three or four
students who act as the mouthpiece for
their organization the class to give me
feedback about what's going on now what
I think is real interesting about using
course committees is first of all I
don't have to talk to every student
because the course committee makes sure
that the general sense of what's going
on is representative Allen and Michael
represented the other purchasing execs I
don't have to talk to all 20 of them I
can talk to a couple of them and we'll
know pretty much what's going on but I
think the other key issue is it gives
them a sense of control I think this
goes back to the point that you raised
I'm sorry your name is Mark the point
that Mark raised which is that
particularly in the context of this
organization's culture if we open up an
inclusive process that promotes buying
and ownership on their part we are not
changing the culture of the organization
by virtue of putting in a process which
makes it more likely that we will be
able to successfully solve the problem
okay I'm gonna turn it over to Margaret
now and she's gonna wrap this up for us
here are the conclusions well part of
what we want to sort of wrap this up
with is a restatement of what we hope is
the obvious now at the end of these two
hours and that is the differences of
perspective of expertise of experience
our critical resources in your
organization and they are oftentimes
underutilized either by the individuals
not being willing to share their
forty's or the team's not being
constructed in a way that allows the
individuals to have those expertise to
have that to allow those expertise and
differences to surface in addition we
have organizations that are highly
conflict avoidant and even if you have
all of the potential solution you have
all the potential perspectives that you
need without conflict they're not going
to be raised and they're not going to be
divergently expressed and then therefore
they can't be convergently used to
basically create to innovate and so
you've got to think about do I have
enough diversity here and we can sort of
go back to a variety of perspectives and
suggest that you know if you have a very
dynamic and changing environment you're
going to need more information diversity
your team's to respond to that dynamic
and changing environment basically
because oftentimes you don't really know
exactly how much information expertise
and diversity you need and so you need
to sort of mirror what's in the
environment the demands from the
environment so there's not enough
information sometimes and when it's
there we oftentimes don't create a
situation where it's easily surfaced so
that we can have access to it
and if we think about this one of the
things that we sort of the the reward
that we get from this process is that as
we are able to surface these differences
and then manage the conflict to be able
to always service them but to get them
to be integrated we create the potential
for innovation for creativity and
adaptation in our groups and one of the
things that we also need is once we've
done all that what that also helps us
with is buy-in and implementation right
because once the maybe the group has
come up with the perfect solution or
maybe post came up with the perfect
solution but if people don't buy into
the process then you're gonna have a
hard time implementing if they're gonna
be a lot of people who you'll either put
aside the letter it wasn't delivered I
never got it right or we have solutions
now where there's nothing worth 50,000
that we purchase so I never have to say
anything to you we find ways around it
if people are bought into the end
limitation are they bought into the
solution the implementation flows much
more easily and so we're trying to
manage multiple processes with these
teams one is to try to get the best
solution to the problem but once we have
that solution we also have to implement
it and so part of what we're going to
we've tried to sort of identify today
it's really a lot of mechanisms to help
you become more effective in utilizing
the resources that